figaro live il est très exactement 20h37
merci d'être avec nous en ce dernier
jour de l'année 2020 cette fameuse
années 2020 qu'on est nombreux à avoir
atteint d'achever de conclure et on va
la concurrence entre justement sur
lefigaro.fr et sur youtube sur la chaîne
youtube de figaro live merci d'être avec
nous on va on va aller prendre le pouls
tient dans les rues de paris vous
apercevez sur ces images les champs
elysées on va regarder aussi ce qui se
joue un peu ailleurs
en direct on a quelques images qui nous
parviennent et bien des du nord pas de
calais et des hauts de france où on se
prépare à rentrer à entrer dans l'ère
post ben l'exit dans cette nouvelle
relation commerciale entre la france
l'union européenne même et le
royaume-uni briques site qui va être
définitivement entrer en vigueur dans
quelques heures dans trois heures dans
un peu plus de trois heures avant ça on
va regarder ce qui se passe justement si
ce couvre feu est bien respectée puisque
c'est un réveillon sous couvre-feu c'est
un réveillon assez hors norme qui
conclut une année hors norme également
envoyez nous vos commentaires sur
lefigaro.fr sûr sur youtube dites nous
ce que vous avez prévu ce soir si vous
réveillonner dans le cadre autorisé ou
en tout cas conseiller dites le nous on
fera pas de délation au vent vous le
promets dites nous voilà comme ce que
vous mangez ce que vous allez écouter
regarder si vous êtes tout seul aussi
bas venez venez trouver un peu de
compagnie chez nous on va on va on va
parler de tout ça il ya cent mille
policiers et gendarmes mobilisés pour ce
pour ce réveillon vous voyez d'ailleurs
ces images en direct des champs elysées
je vous le disais on va rejoindre tout
de suite bien thibault il aurait qui est
l'envoyé spécial figaro live sur la plus
belle avenue du monde pour sortir ou
plus belle avenue du monde où il n'y a
pas grand monde ce soir finalement
exactement alors attendez je reprends ma
caméra bonsoir pierre bonsoir à tous
la plus belle avenue du monde en effet
qui est bien tout à fait quadrillée par
les forces de l'ordre
vous avez pu le voir derrière moi bien
qu'elles n'ont de la gendarmerie avec
ses membres des gendarmes qui sont ici
mais en train de filtrer les trottoirs
pour rappeler aux passants qu'il est
l'heure de rentrer chez soi on a
également à travers ces camions des haut
parleurs qui depuis tout à l'heure et
bien appel est signé appelle les
citoyens à rentrer chez eux gendarmerie
nationale le couvre-feu a lieu de 20h à
6h du matin veuillez même entraîner des
annonces au mégaphone un fait part
faites par les forces de l'ordre c'est
ce que vous nous dites thibault comment
ça se passe et ce que est ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde finalement qui a qui
arrivent face aux forces de l'ordre
comment se déroule le condé les
contrôles à l'heure actuelle bah je vais
vous le montrez vous voyez ici en direct
qu'un contrôle a actuellement lieu par
ses forces de la police qui ont contrôlé
mois également demandé pourquoi j'étais
là j'étais montrer ma carte de presse et
de l'autre côté et bien pouvait donc se
calment de la gendarmerie qui
quadrillent littéralement la plus belle
avenue du monde depuis tout à l'heure
quelques taxis qui passent quelques
véhicules également qu'ils sont à l'eau
filtrée de façon sporadique et on va
aller bien au milieu de cette avenue
alors on va peut-être attendre que le
petit bonhomme soit vers voilà on est
bon et vous le voyez bien cette avenue
qui est littéralement peut-être pas
déserte il ya quand même pas mal de
monde entre les forces de l'ordre et les
quelques véhicules qui circulent mais de
l'autre côté c'est beaucoup plus
significatif
vous pouvez le voir là le filtre est
assez imposant est assez important avec
plusieurs petits bas qui sont arrêtés
donc voilà pas être beaucoup beaucoup de
trafic mais quand même quelques derniers
passant qui biens circulent sur l'avenue
pour ba soit rentrés chez eux sous va se
déplacer
merci thibout pour c'est pour ces
premières précisions alors je veux
saluer toutes celles et ceux qui nous
ont déjà rejoints sur lefigaro.fr est
sûre et sur youtube merci d'être avec
nous on est ravis de conclure l'année
avec vous et on se retrouvera bien
évidemment dès demain dès 2021
bonjour marouane
e
bonjour
bandana jean-loup nasser qui sont
avec nous je vois également 0 tout bonne
année vous ne souhaitez déjà les voeux
bas merci 0 tôt merci d'être avec nous
on souhaite la bonne année également sur
figaro live je vois et maquettes avec
nous je vois également thierry merci
merci d'être là a des alliés qui est
avec nous sur lefigaro.fr l'important
est ce qui se passe dedans et non dehors
alors effectivement c'est vrai que j'ai
pas forcément sur plan sanitaire n'est
pas forcément ce qui va se passer dehors
qui inquiète peut-être le plus mais mais
plutôt les les rassemblements privé et
rassemblements privée justement thibault
on va faire un petit point là dessus les
autorités avec le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin la ministre
déléguée marlène schiappa se sont encore
exprimés ces dernières heures pour faire
le point sur ces fameux rassemblement
privé ans
oui en effet on a eu pas mal de
déclarations aussi et beaucoup bien de
questions de questionnement et une
inquiétude
on va justement abordé cette question
des rassemblements privé pendant que moi
je vais quitter la plus belle avenue du
monde les champs elysées pour vous
orienter vers cette direction vers la
place de l'étoile
alors tout à l'heure c'est assez
gendarme derrière moi m'ont dit qu'il
fallait qu'on tournait bien par par des
avenues adjacentes pour pouvoir se
rendre sur la place donc on va faire un
petit détour le temps d'aborder ce thème
mais en effet donc les rassemblent en
privé qu'ils sont et bien au coeur de
toutes les interrogations à la fois des
citoyens mais également des autorités
qui est bien espère par un pic lié aux
célébrations du nouvel an est donc bon
c'est pierre tout d'abord et bien c'est
cette limite qui est conseillère qui
n'est pas obligatoire mais qui est
fortement conseillée par les autorités
sanitaires et administratives de six
personnes à l'intérieur on va on va
suivre tout ça alors vous me dites que
le son résonne sur sur youtube on va
essayer de faire un petit réglage or
c'est vrai que nos micros elles sont pas
forcément mieux armé pour éviter les
résonances en tout cas merci de votre
vigilance pour votre vigilance sur notre
chaîne youtube bonjour nous dit adam
nicolas bonne année bah je suis en
avance mais bonne année nous dira dans
aussi mais merci d'être avec nous tiens
dites-nous j'aimerais bien savoir quels
ont été vos souvenirs
pour cette année ah les bons comme les
mauvais on va essayer de parler des bons
d'abord qu'est ce qui vous a marqué
positivement cette année qu'est-ce que
vous avez le plus vite envie d'oublier
qu'est ce que vous espérez ne pas
retrouver l'année prochaine dit le nous
aussi parlé nous aussi des événements
d'actualité qui vous ont marqué
également
bonjour à coco qui est avec nous bonjour
à anna également qui nous fait un petit
coucou waking qui nous dit bonsoir merci
merci d'être là et on est ensemble dans
les rues de paris on est tout près des
champs elysées les rues de paris qui
sont très déserte ce soir oui c'est le
couvre feu
un couvre feu qui a débuté il y a trois
quarts d'heure environ
comme c'est le cas depuis le 15 décembre
il ya une exception
le soir du 24 le sort du 24 décembre
pour le réveillon de noël mais on
retourne sous couvre-feu et couvre feu
qui sera en vigueur jusqu'à 6h du matin
alors il ya eu beaucoup de
de d'articles d'information faisant état
d'achats en masse de duvet ou de matelas
gonflable ces dernières heures ces
derniers jours on a même publié un
article c'est en page 2 du figaro de
notre édition du jour un article d'agnès
leclerc où vous avez des témoignages de
gens qui de personnes deux français
jeunes moins jeunes qui racontent
comment ils vont passer leur nouvel an
et avec un afflux un affluent tout
simplement chez certaines personnes
on souhaite un bon courage à toutes
celles et ceux qui vont accueillir bien
cette armée de sacs de couchage de duvet
et de matelas gonflable et bien pour
accueillir les proches pour ce nouvel an
la plus belle avenue du monde expression
type du français se croyant seul au
monde nous dit à dld sur lefigaro.fr bah
tiens on va engendrer un petit débat
avec thibault il aurait qui est
justement sur les champs elysées ce
qu'on sait pour qu'on dit la plus belle
avenue du monde finalement
je dirais d'ailleurs qu'il ya quand même
une résonance internationale avec avec
cette expression qui est certes franco
centrer mais bon ce qui se passe sur les
champs-elysées et quand même suivi à
l'international systématiquement pour un
exemple je viens de faire un tweet il ya
quelques minutes je peux vous dire que
tout de suite une reprise de plein
d'étrangers
parce qu'en fait c'est aussi le symbole
de paris cette ville qui est scruté par
de nombreux voisins internationale on
comprend
son micro on prend vos commentaires en
direct avec avec thibaut historiens ont
débrief on vit ce qui se passe en ce
moment du côté de paris et puis on va
débriefer aussi cette année ensemble je
vois quelques commentaires
que la vaccination commence vite nous
dit julien sûr sur youtube
effectivement ça commence ça a commencé
ça a commencé en fin de semaine dernière
mais c'est vrai que ça se fait au compte
gouttes pour l'instant en début de
semaine on comptait à peine 70 personnes
vaccinées que ce soit
bien du côté de dijon ou du côté de
sevran en région parisienne la plus
belle avenue du monde est déserte c'est
honteux nous dit alex et bien on va
justement continuer de faire ce point
avec avec thibaut la plus belle avenue
du monde qui les quais déserts mais
pourtant mais pourtant ce soir veillée
voir quelques événements festifs ça va
se dérouler ailleurs notamment du côté
du louverain thibault dans quelques
heures
exactement alors vous avez trois gros
rassemblement qui seront télévisées mais
qui seront bel et bien organisée mais à
100 publique tout d'abord et bien c'est
comme vous l'avez dit du côté du lourd
ça ce sera à partir de minuit avec un
événement de david guetta qui va faire
un show musical et lumineux sur la
fameuse pyramide du lot de l'autre côté
vous avez aussi un événement musical de
jean michel jarre niveau de notre dame
de paris et enfin à partir de 21h ça ce
sera sur france 2 vous avez un spectacle
musical merci pour ces précisions
thibault effectivement alors moi je vais
plutôt choisir le concert de david
guetta parce que je suis un grand
amateur de musiques électroniques dites
nous si vous avez regardé ces événements
sur notre chaîne youtube par exemple
nous sur notre chaîne youtube si vous
comptez regarder ces événements ce que
malheureusement non pas les droits de
diffusion je sais que tf1 va rediffuser
vers 1h20 du matin le 7 de david guetta
qui va se jouer à son et lumière
exceptionnel qui est annoncé du côté du
louvre et qui commence si j'ai bien lu à
23h45
bon courage aux journalistes d'astreinte
nous dit cnc alors ça c'est un message
qui nous fait plaisir
bon courage aux journalistes d'astreinte
à écouter oui merci merci beaucoup c'est
vrai que il me semble que je n'ai pas
encore vu arriver les les convois de
champagne et autres petits fours du côté
des locaux du figaro y semble-t-il eu un
quelques quelques restrictions cette
année ben oui on a encore beaucoup en
télétravail en tout cas on salue aussi
nos amis de la homepage qui sont là pour
alimenter le site en temps réel et nos
amis des réseaux sociaux ainsi que tous
nos collègues de figaro live qui sont
bas de leur côté en train de de festoyer
de l'alcool avec modération à nous dit
justement un internaute sur sur youtube
fait attention va écouter
merci et de rappeler ses messages
important également
merci merci a dit vick qui est là avec
nous également sur youtube bonsoir merci
d'être là avec david guetta bastien vous
allez regarder david guetta ce soir
merci pour ces pour ces précisions
vous allez avoir 20 ans l'année
prochaine voilà c'est dur d'avoir 20 en
2020 a dit emmanuel macron tout à
l'heure dans ses voeux il est revenu
aussi sur le fameux quoi qu'il en coûte
je sais pas si vous avez suivi les voeux
des manuels maquereau en tout cas vous
pouvez retrouver les meilleurs extraits
sur rome lefigaro.fr
il ya notamment eu cette liste de
prénoms qui a été égrénés par le chef de
l'état romain gendarmes
rosalie libraire morissette la première
vacciner contre le coc vie de 78 ans
mauricette voilà il ya eu cette liste de
personnalités entre guillemets des connu
des moins connus wendy footballeuses qui
a gagné la ligue des champions et qui
ont marqué finalement cette année 2020
il ya eu également bien les prénoms des
trois gendarmes qui ont été sauvagement
tués on peut le dire dans le puy de dôme
ces derniers jours les trois militaires
français qui sont morts qui sont tombées
sur le front dans le nord-mali il y a
quelques jours également du côté de
hombori -qui voyagé à bord d'un véhicule
blindé léger et qui ont été touché par
un engin explosif improvisé ses voeux
des manuels macron tous ces prénoms que
le chef de l'état cités sont les tous
ces visages sont ceux de la france en
2020 terre nous saurons faire face aux
crises les premiers mois seront
difficiles au moins jusqu'au printemps
on nous parlait de voeux des manuels
macron qui ne serait pas uniquement
centré sur la crise sanitaire mais
évidemment un difficile de l'occulté et
des premiers mois qui s'annoncent
difficiles au moins jusqu'au printemps
printemps le 20 mars et est donc
effectivement c'est vrai que il y aurait
dans les deux premiers mois à peine un
million de personnes vaccinées si on en
croit les les estimations faites donc
effectivement commence sur un rythme
assez lent et ce vaccin ce vaccin qui a
été longuement évoquée évidemment par le
chef de l'état en rappelant que bien on
va commencer par vacciner ceux qui
présentent
le plus de risques on va retourner voir
si vous continuez de commenter sur
lefigaro.fr et sur sur notre chaîne
youtube
dites nous ce qui vous a marqué cette
année dit nous aussi parce que vous
attendez de 2021 ce que vous espérez si
vous passer des concours des examens
diplôme si vous essayez de progresser en
cuisine si vous attendez avec impatience
des films les films aussi c'est un sujet
vous avez peut-être vu qu'on l'avait
abordé récemment dans le figaro l'état
du cinéma en france le développement des
plateformes de streaming et de vidéo à
la demande
dites nous voilà ce que vous attendez
avec impatience que vous attendez moi on
est ensemble sur lefigaro.fr et sur
youtube
on va retourner voir thibault du côté
est bien de l'arc de triomphe au pied
duquel se trouvent quelques camions de
police
exactement pierre cette place de
l'étoile qui est bien pour ce soir une
place très symbolique avec au loin
cette flamme du soldat inconnu qui
continue de briller évidemment est-ce
que vous pouvez voir et bien c'est
plusieurs camions de la police qui sont
stationnés ici sur cette place alors
c'est intéressant ça fait un peu écho à
des images qu'on a pu voir ces dernières
semaines dans un tout autre contexte
avec les manifestations des policiers
dans un contexte très compliqué pour eux
et aussi très critique hier puisque on
est en plein débat toujours de la loi
sécurité globale et du schéma national
du match irlande est donc bien cette
fois ci ces camions de le défense de
l'ordre sont bel et bien ici pour
réguler la circulation et surtout et
bien tous les environs des
champs-elysées ces images
particulièrement symbolique vous le
voyez aussi ses forces de la gendarmerie
qui sont ici pour quadriller la place et
vous le voyez aussi on va se lire les
confrères ici de france info qui vient
aussi de façon symbolique puisque les
médias ont été omniprésents dans la rue
cette année est bien ici pour les
différents live qui ont lieu on le
disait tout à l'heure à 7 plus belle
avenue du monde qui est quand même
extrêmement symbolique même à l'échelle
internationale et si on le voit avec la
présence des médias est l'essence de
l'oxydé d'azoté réguler les micros merci
pour ces précisions
merci pour ces précisions thibault une
question quand même une jeu mais je
règle mon micro une question voilà
imaginons ce soir je suis dans les rues
de paris
quel est le motif de paris ou d'une
autre ville d'ailleurs d'une autre ville
d'une d'une ville plus petite d'un
village quel motif qu'elle est
quels motifs et que je le droit de me
déplacer
alors vous avez plusieurs motifs tout
d'abord et bien ce sont pour des
placements professionnels comme c'est
mon cas moi je dispose de s'être essayé
de ne pas la perdre sinon je vais pas
passer la soirée dans les rues mais au
poste ma carte de presse évidemment on a
aussi toutes les attestations
professionnels qui vont pouvoir être
utilisé pour justifier de vos
déplacements
ce que vous avez aussi et bien ce sont
les déplacements inter régions si vous
disposez des exposés par exemple d'un
billet de train ou d'avion qui atteste
que vous arrivez bien de votre voyage et
balas a fait office de l'attestation est
ensuite eh bien ce sera pour des
placements pour motifs médicaux pour
motifs familiaux impérieux ou encore
pour certains motifs comme par exemple
sortir son animal de compagnie mais
seulement à une distance réglementés de
votre domicile et vous aussi vous avez
choisi d'aller chez des amis jeu alors
il va falloir trouver un bout de canapé
un parce que sinon vous allez risquer
une amende certains certains vont braver
le les interdits finalement c'est le
long et des ex primaire dans les
colonnes du figaro c'est un article vous
pouvez retrouvez dans l'édition du jour
notamment kukumi qui nous dit j'ai une
pensée pour michou un roi du grand
boulevard une pensée pour giscard une
pensée pour claude brasseur
pour robert hossein et oui robert
hossein dont on a appris la disparition
aujourd'hui à 1,93
pierre cardin pour ennio morricone tous
les autres que d'année marqué par la
mort et oui et c'est vrai qu'on pourrait
inciter tellement d'autres on a eu six
îles en mer
quand on a appris la disparition cette
année on a eu guy bedos
on a eu jean loup dabadie j'ai pas le
jeu ne sais pas si si on a eu plus de
célébrités en france qui ont disparu par
rapport aux autres années mais c'est
vrai que cette année on
on n'a pas été gâté on n'a pas été gâté
on a perdu des visages des voix des voix
aussi roger carel des voix qui nous
étaient familières un roger carel
astérix souvenons nous quel est votre
astérix préféré en bd ou en film tient
dites le moi dans le tchat sur youtube
ou sur lefigaro.fr j'aimerais savoir ça
merci en tout cas d'être d'être avec
nous et c'est vrai qu'on a une pensée
merci coucou de nous avoir rappelé cette
liste nous on a une pensée pour bien
toutes ces personnalités qui nous ont
quittés cette année
kirk douglas vous nous dites également
alors que divine nous parle de michou le
youtuber alors c'est vrai que en 2020 on
peut aussi parler de michou le youtube
heures revenons en revenons si vous le
voulez bien dans les rues de paris
je voyais un message passé aussi voilà
je suis moi qui nous dit quand je vois
paris ce soir on se croit en corée du
nord bon voilà la comparaison paraît
quand même assez assez osée mais c'est
vrai que thibaut où l'on se le disait en
préparant ce live on a quand même la
sensation d'assister ce soir même si on
peut dire ça de pour toute l'année mais
on a l'impression ce soir d'assister à
quelque chose d'historique à nouveau
exactement d'ailleurs ben moi j'ai prévu
d'être ce soir ici tu la soirée parce
que j'avais vraiment le sentiment tant
que journaliste on était sûr sur quelque
chose qu'on voit absolument pas souvent
c'est pas assez rare qu'on voit c'est
cette avenue des champs-elysées déserté
en tout cas quadrillé dans un contexte
où d'habitude les biens ce sont des
milliers de personnes rassemblées ici
avec un feu d'artifice des spectacles
ils sont projetés sur l'arc de triomphe
juste derrière moi et donc c'est vrai
que c'est particulièrement important
j'entendais ce commentaire sur l'accord
et je dois dire je dois le préciser je
suis souvent très critique quand il faut
du travail des forces de l'ordre inverse
je suis aussi le dire quand il est bien
fait et donc bien là je dois dire que en
tout cas le contrôle des forces de l'anp
est particulièrement apaisé on n'est pas
du tout dans une intention en tout cas
une une rudesse dans les contrôles j'ai
vu beaucoup beaucoup de contrôle certes
mais en tout cas très peu de semble-t-il
d'interpellations d'amande qui sont
fixés ici sur les champs elysées vous
voyez aussi un beau coup de véhicules
qui continuent de passer de circuler et
surtout que j'ai pu bien échangé
plusieurs fois avec les forces de
l'ordre qui m'ont contrôler c'est
beaucoup moins strictes et et ruud je
dirais que lorsque eh bien on est dans
un contexte de manifestations car
effectivement merci merci thibault pour
pour ces précisions on admire vos belles
images de l'arc de triomphe
ce taxi qui est qui et là je regarde les
messages que vous nous envoyez sur en
direct sur lefigaro.fr sur youtube
également deux points qui nous dit je
vous regarde du texas et bonjour à vous
parce qu'avec le décalage horaire un bon
jour on doit quand même être aux
alentours de la mi journée
dis tu nous tiens comment vous
réveillonner du côté du texas est ce que
vous aller réveillonner quels sont les
ânes ou fait plaisir aussi d'avoir des
témoignages de l'étranger je me rappelle
quand avec thibault on faisait les live
pendant le confinement on avait des
témoignages venus d'autriche venus de
république tchèque des états unis de new
york et et vous nous décrivent y est
avec précision quelle était la situation
sur place vis-à-vis de de la circulation
de ce virus les mesures sanitaires ou
autre avez-vous les chiffres des
voitures brûlées ce soir alors écoutez
on vont déjà alors si il y à un chiffre
est beaucoup trop tôt pour pour l'avoir
et le communiqué il est il est aux
alentours de 21h et puis ba ba ty bos
intéressant on peut faire un point là
dessus c'est vrai que depuis des années
on ne communique plus sur les chiffres
de voitures brûlées ou en tout cas
extrêmement peu ans oui alors certes il
est déjà en plus tôt pour parler de
voitures brûlées en plus bas on ne sait
pas encore de quoi sera faite cette
soirée met en effet en ce qui concerne
ces types de chiffres c'est toujours
très symbolique du nouvel an mais il est
toujours très difficile de les commenter
déjà pour les autorités mais également
pour les observateurs civils que nous
sommes et donc pierre je souhaitais vous
montrer ces images aussi qui sont
intéressantes on va s'orienter un petit
peu plus en direction de cette avenue
des champs-elysées qu'on peut voir bien
en amont et en aval et en fait moi vous
ne me voyez pas exactement
vous la jouer ce qu'on peut observer
c'est bien c'est la station tout
simplement en charge de gaulle étoile
qui a été fermée au public c'est l'une
des rares citations mais rien qui a été
fermée puisque la plupart des stations
elles sont ouvertes pour les regarde
en tout cas pour certaines lignes comme
là où l'abbé je souhaitais aussi abordé
la question des transports si vous êtes
franciliens et bien ces transports qui
ont été quand même vachement régulier
avec près de 2 sur 9 200 stations
fermées ce soit et sinon une régulation
assez importante puisque est bien de
nombreuses stations ou en tout cas ligne
seront fermés du côté du de 21h jusqu'à
6h heure de fin du couvre-feu et donc si
vous souhaitez vous déplacez sachez que
seront ouvertes jusqu'à une heure du
matin et ça c'est une fois n'est pas
coutume et bien les stations une alors 2
4,9
c'est vrai qu'il ya quatre ans mercy
thibout pour pour ces précisions il ya
près de 200 stations qui sont fermées ce
soir vous avez des lignes qui sont
complètement à l'arrêt comme la 3 comme
m
10 et maintien si vous avez un métro à
prendre ce soir si vous comptez bah
voila vous déplacer avant une heure du
matin même si a priori c'est interdire
si vous n'avez pas de motifs dit nos
demandes et nous on va regarder si votre
ligne circule bienvenue à alma bienvenue
à marie-hélène bonjour de londres où
tout est mort puisque nous sommes en
en confinement tout le monde reste chez
soi bonne année 2021 à tous les français
vive le brésil
je vous cite un marie-hélène vive le
breakbeat ce soir nous nous serons
libres
bah écoutez moi ça m'attriste un peu ce
qui se passe du côté de londres puisque
les matches de premier league sont
reportés les uns après les autres
tottenham fulham hier par exemple
évidemment évidemment c'est une
nécessité de de protéger la population
et vous nous parler du breakbeat je vais
vous citer boris johnson boris johnson
le premier ministre britannique qui
s'est exprimé tout à l'heure qui a
présenté ses voeux également le royaume
uni sera ouvert généreux et tournée vers
l'extérieur
c'est ce que
bien a déclaré boris johnson dans ses
voeux dans son allocution
c'est un moment incroyable nous avons
notre liberté entre nos mains il nous
revient d'en tirer le meilleur parti
voilà c'est sont les propos de beaux
jours dans son allocution du nouvel an
effectivement le brésil devient réalité
on l'avait vécu ensemble si antibes on
va grâce à marie hélène en reparler
c'est un de nos grands souvenirs
journalistique aussillon on l'avait vécu
ce break site
le 31 janvier 1 vous étiez même à
londres on avait fini soirée spéciale
exactement j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
couvrir cet événement historique
il ya bientôt un an vous étiez vous en
direct à paris pour commenter cela en
studio et c'est vrai que c'est un grand
moment à suivre
moi j'avais pu suivre en direct deux
événements là bas ce soir le 31 janvier
le premier c'était en fin d'après-midi
avec ce qu'on appelait les eaux claires
ce qui reste en anglais c'était bien des
manifestants
reminders exactement merci qui étaient
des manifestants bien pro européens qui
étaient déjà vu de nombreuses personnes
pleurer les larmes aux yeux au pied du
siège britannique de l'union européenne
a juste à côté de big ben est ensuite et
bien les breaks sitters ceux qui partent
littéralement en tout cas c'est une
traduction un peu pas très littérale
mais très significative de ces
britanniques qui étaient ravis de voir
la grande bretagne quitté l'union
européenne et qui donc avait célébré
cela jusqu'à environ une heure du matin
et ça c'était et bien plusieurs semaines
avant une période beaucoup plus complexe
c'est l'homme
d'auschwitz
sur le figaro.fr bonsoir etienne merci
d'être avec nous vous réagissez aux
propos point ministre britannique gb au
kenya il ya quelques instants
si vous devez etien prendre l'eurostar
soyez rassurés la carte d'identité
suffit jusqu'au 1er octobre prochain 1er
octobre 2021
et puis enfin concernant la pêche c'est
l'inde et l'une des mesures de cet
accord c'est 1246 page si vous changez
de la lecture bahia l'accord des futures
relations entre l'union européenne et le
royaume uni qui est disponible 1246 page
si vous parlez anglais que vous avez
envie de lire la pêche y aura eu une
réduction petit à petit sur cinq ans et
demi jusqu'en juin 2000 26 2 bat des
quotas et surtout de la valeur 25 % en
valeur c'est ce à quoi doivent renoncer
les re les européens d'ici juin 2000
26,2 points notre internaute qui a comme
pseudo deux points qui nous dit qu'il va
célébrer donc toujours au texas
bien sûr ce nouvel an avec des amis à
taulé to bend laïque j'espère que je
n'ai koch pas le nom de cette ville au
texas en tout cas merci merci de nous
regarder
et merci d'être d'être avec nous
pourquoi thibault a le masque s'il n'y a
personne à côté de lui
pas parce que si thibault enlève le
masque alors qu' il est entouré de
forces de l'ordre ben il va y avoir 135
euros en moins sur son salaire un team
vaud oui j'ai le droit de sortir grâce à
mon l'attestation professionnelle mais
j'ai un endroit aussi de respecter la
loi et la loi instaure qu'on respecte
les gestes barrières et on respecte
aussi et bien cette ce port du masque
systématique dans la rue même si il ya
soi-disant personne mais il ya quand
même pas mal de monde autour de moi ce
sont plusieurs dizaines de personnes
entre quelques journalistes même si je
trouve que la présence médiatique et est
relativement faible ce soir est aussi
bien les forces de l'anp dans présence
ici alors vous en parliez tout à l'heure
mais
en tout cas beaucoup de cette présence
des personnes ici présentes font notion
à l'actualité avec ici ces camions de la
gendarmerie qui bien sont en deuil et de
la perte de 3,2 le roman n'a pu suivre
ça en direct sur foot et en live lundi
avec un robert et bien un hommage des
différentes autorités présentes et donc
bien ses forces de la police qui sont
elles aussi sur les yeux d'un sous les
projecteurs depuis désormais plusieurs
semaines avec l'actualité très forte en
ce qui semblait 6 et gendarmes déployés
ce soir un thibaut sur le territoire
national exactement qui sont présents
pour pour quadriller quadriller le
territoire et s'assurer que le
couvre-feu est bel et bien respecté
cette présence et surtout 7
cette force déployée elle est aussi
intéressante et on va vous rappeler
aussi comment elle doit fonctionner en
ce qui concerne les soirées vous allez
faire chez vous alors vous n'êtes pas
bien interdits de soirée chez vous si
vous faites une soirée par exemple on
sait donc le chiffre qui est conseillée
mais qui n'est pas obligatoire et de six
personnes même si les autorités
sanitaires
monde les conseillers déjà si ce n'est
même pas plus et de l'autre côté et bien
sachez que vous êtes chez vous ne pouvez
pas être en tout cas pénalisé si vous
faites un rassemblement après il ya
plein de certaines conditions qu'il est
important de prendre en compte
à commencer par celle du tapage nocturne
bien évidemment qui peut vous être
verbalisé à 68 euros
de l'autre côté vous pouvez aussi être
dénoncés pour gène occasionnée l'a fait
en fonction et de l'autre côté bien
sachez que les forces de l'ordre n'ont
pas droit de rentrer chez vous sans
votre autorisation
toutefois le peuvent verbaliser selon ce
qu'elle observe de la porte par exemple
et ça ça dépend vraiment de la situation
mais si par exemple les bains merci à
tous points très précis un thibault sûr
parce qu'on est en cours ainsi on
enfreint les règles merci aussi pour vos
superbes images de cet arc de triomphe
qui est bien est illuminée pour une
dernière fois en 2020 michael ou michael
je ne sais pas en tout cas bienvenue
merci d'être avec nous vous nous écrivez
de suisse et vous nous dites pas que
c'est pareil en suisse il n'y a personne
dans les rues
spectacle assez étrange bah oui et comme
mon avis on peut retrouver on imagine
retrouvez aussi dans dans pas mal de
pays deux pays frontaliers notamment en
italie entre autres n'hésitez pas si
vous nous écrivez
dites-nous d'où vous nous écrivez tiens
d'ailleurs que vous soyez en france ou
dans un autre pays dites nous comment ça
se passe chez vous merci en tout cas
pour vos témoignages pablo qui nous dit
bonsoir à toutes et tous avec cette
emoji d un très bel emoji peut-être mon
préféré d'ailleurs celui de deux coupes
de champagne qui trinquent
merci beaucoup pablo à vous faites
beaucoup plus vous me fait bien plaisir
là
alors après on a aussi bombardé
internautes qui nous disent c'est ça le
journalisme de filmer des rues vidées de
faire du bison futé à écouter on si on
ne fait rien on nous dit qu'on ne fait
rien si on fait quelque chose on est
également critique et donc on va essayer
de trouver un jeu un juste milieu
voilà on peut faire des dédicaces par
exemple pierre une petite dédicace stp
jeanjean merci bah merci jeanjean d'être
avec nous merci jean si vous avez eu une
grand mère a embrassé en respectant les
eaux fait-il froid nous dit la frite
froide bat justement on va parler on va
parler de ça vous certains ont peut-être
nous reprocher de faire de la météo mais
mais c'est un élément qui le froid
justement qui fait partie et bien des
éléments qui inquiète les autorités dans
la circulation du virus
on a également parlé d'un couvre-feu
thibault avancé à 18 heures qu'en est-il
là dessus
il va falloir attendre alors là je
n'aurais pas forcément l'information sur
ce couvre-feu
je peux vous donner en tout cas le
ressenti ici il fait et très exactement
4 degrés donc pour un mois de décembre
c'est plutôt positif et on continue on
continue de prendre vos messages
évidemment sur sur figaro live sur
lefigaro.fr est sûre
youtube on est ensemble on est également
on est également sur twitch ah bah ça y
est on a réparé twitch il me semblait
que
c'était cassé mais dont on est on est
ensemble et je vois soral qui est avec
nous qui nous dit bonjour est ce que ma
kron a déjà parlé oui c'était tout à
l'heure les voeux des manuels macron que
vous pouvez retrouver un pont dans ses
écrits sur le figaro.fr
alors emmanuel macron ça a été des voeux
assez particulier cette année
emmanuel macron qui était assis dans un
fauteuil et on a quitté il a quitté le
le cadre très strict du bureau avec le
jardin de l'elysée en arrière-plan
peut-être peut-être on le saura
peut-être dans des articles à venir sur
lefigaro.fr peut-être pour évacuer cette
image des allocutions solennelles nous
annonçant des nouvelles contraignante
restrictives dans cette année 2020 ses
nombreuses allocutions on se souvient
notamment qu entre mars et avril bas on
a le droit à plusieurs allocutions nous
annonçant le confinement nous annonçant
la fermeture des écoles et puis rebelote
en fin d'année aux alentours de la mi
octobre et de la fin octobre le
couvre-feu le deuxième confinement ça
fait beaucoup ça fait beaucoup alors
peut-être est-ce qu'il y avait peut-être
y avait-il une volonté de rompre avec
bien ce cadre très strict pour l'
annonce de mauvaises nouvelles en tout
cas voilà c'était un emmanuel macron
dans dans un fauteuil qui qui a expliqué
qu' revenu sur son quoi qu'il en coûte
il la cité à nouveau son quoi qu'il en
coûte jeu l'assument
cela a permis de protéger des vies de
sauver des emplois a dit le chef de
l'état dans les rumeurs qui ont précédé
les voeux des manuels macron on nous
annonçait des voeux qui serait tournée
vers la jeunesse est bien à emmanuel
macron et affirmé que la france a été un
des pays qui en a fait le plus pour la
jeunesse au sein de cette crise
économique et sociale
surtout pour les jeunes il y a eu cette
liste de prénoms j'en parlais tout à
l'heure
romain le gendarme rosalie la libraire
morissette la première vacciner contre
le coc vide
wendy la footballeuse il ya eu ce
ce panorama un peu ce set cette voie là
ce cet arbre cette famille française vue
par emmanuel macron tous ces prénoms ces
visages ceux de la france at il dit
évoquant bien les luttes contre le coc
vie d'un élu le portrait d'une
infirmière également le portrait de
pompiers de gendarmes qui vont sauver
des vies en raison de la crise du covin
mais aussi en raison des autres crises d
autres mots que traverse la société
française
il ya eu également une pensée pour les
trois gendarmes et les trois militaires
qui ont été tués récemment que ce soit
dans le puy de dôme pour les gendarmes
que ce soit au mali pour les militaires
de l'opération bar kane qui ont perdu la
vie du côté dont borie il y a quelques
jours il ya eu également la luz ion au
vaccin
une bonne partie de l'allocution a aussi
consacré aux vaccins commençaient pas
vacciner 1 ceux qui présentent le plus
de risques qu'un pad annonce pad annonce
finalement dans ses voeux mais le
contexte n'était pas à celui le temps
n'était pas celui des annonces de
nouvelles annonces
il faut être fier d'être nous d'être
français d'être patriote emmanuel macron
qui a souhaité une année 2021 heureuse
et utiles et qui a affirmé qu'en 2021
nous saurons faire face aux crises gris
sanitaire sociale faire face au
terrorisme les premiers mois seront
difficiles au moins jusqu'au printemps
au moins jusqu'au printemps c'est ce
qu'a déclaré le chef de l'état
voilà pour cette allocution résumé un
bon soir également à dr maboul et
on a beaucoup d'humour dans le sud nous
dit dr bach avec vous ayez beaucoup
d'humour
si vous avez une bonne blague aussi que
ce soit sur le figaro.fr sur twitch sur
youtube on l'apprend on la prend avec
grand plaisir
ouf que thibault le journaliste de garde
le 31
le journaliste dans le froid thibault
vous est saluée par notre communauté
twitch ça fait plaisir
merci on les salue avec très grand
plaisir puisque on a eu la chance
pierre de couvrir toute l'actualité de
cette année dans la rue du moins sur le
terrain et sur twitch aussi avec une
communauté super qu'on a plaisir à
saluer et qu'on a plaisir à celle
annoncée par thiery qui est avec nous
sur le figaro.fr
alors juste un mot avant etienne qui
nous dit les gendarmes sont aussi des
militaires merci pour ce rappel etienne
distinguer bien
biden dans le cadre de l'opération bien
à des violences pour vous gamme
e
la vie au mali les militaires de
l'opération barkan qui rira je vous
soumets cette question tient thibault à
quoi servent les camions de police
convoi gare et toutes les voitures qui
circulent à côté sont tranquilles c'est
aberrant qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre à
notre internaute alors je répondrais
parce que moi j'ai l'habitude inde et
les contrôles policiers pour couvrir la
grande majorité des manifestations
parisiennes et va cette scène je la
connais plus que bien puisque c'est
exactement ce qu'on aperçoit en
encadrement des différentes
manifestations et des différents
événements urbains
on peut observer ici à paris et donc
tous ces camions sont nombreux certes il
y en a sur l'ensemble de la vue avec et
bien notamment certains véhicules comme
un véhicule de ce type de la gendarmerie
qui quadrillent la l'avenue et qui fait
des allers-retours ce que vous pouvez
aussi observé je vais zoomer pour vous
montrer exactement ce qu'on peut
observer c'est cet appareil dans le dos
du policier qui est tout simplement un
haut parleur fiscale et les forces de
l'ordre police et gendarmerie procède à
des appels selon la tup les tout à un
certain nombre de temps pour appeler les
citoyens à rentrer chez eux et leur
rappelant que le couvre-feu a lieu de
20h à 6h du matin est donc bien vous ne
demandiez pourquoi les véhicules
circulent eh bien je dirais avant tout
parce que eh bien on sent vraiment en
tout cas dans les contrôles qui ont lieu
ici qui est pourtant le point
névralgique
les rassemblements parisiens pour cette
soirée et qui est l'autre surveillance
mais qui est donc s'il est aussi d'un
apaisement assez important ce soir il
n'y a pas de zèle du tout dans les
contrôles qui sont faits même s'il ya
beaucoup de contrôles qui sont faits
vous envoyez un juste ici et donc cette
avance younès et a précisé on voit ici
en tout cas bien un apaisement certain
en ce qui concerne les contrôles et bien
c'est très merci c'est gentil c'est pour
ces précisions merci pour vos images
jolie les champs nous dit un internaute
sur lefigaro.fr vous être nombreux ce
soir sur lefigaro.fr sur tweets sur
youtube
merci d'être là et alors moi il ya
quelque chose qui me fait vraiment
plaisir c'est que vous me dites ce que
vous faites ce soir et vous me dites
notamment comment vous égayer votre
votre réveillon alors ils tiennent qui
salue les policiers les gendarmes
je voyais un message de naves roche qui
nous dit bonsoir depuis les alpes les
enfants sont à 600 ou douze mille
kilomètres on n'a jamais autant parlé
nav roche qui ajoute un jeu vient
d'ouvrir un vieux médoc
un vin millésimé biston briette le vient
le vin vient de me dire que c'était dur
d'avoir 20 ans merci en tout cas pour
votre message qui en fait comme
d'avranches dites nous comment vous
rêvez d'un coup d'envoi c'est la fin de
l'année c'est un peu difficile comment
vous réveillonner ce soir avec qui
comment vous vous occupez est ce qui est
une chanson vous écoutez la playlist
hein dites le nous en malheureusement on
n'a pas le droit pour diffuser des
chansons c'est dommage on peut on peut
pas on peut pas se faire une petite
playlist ensemble mais en tout cas on
est ravi d'avoir vos messages et de
passer ce ce réveillon ensemble
lucky luke une petite pensée pour pierre
pour moi tiens à vous et que vous
préféreriez être avec vos potes plutôt
qu'avec nous a écoutés on vous prenez un
peu de court parce qu'en fait évidemment
je ne sais pas c'est pas contradictoire
on peut très bien aller faire un petit
au réveillon
après après ce live mais en tout cas
dans ça me fait vraiment plaisir d'être
avec vous puisque l'année a été
difficile pour tout le monde et l'année
a été difficile également pour les
journalistes ne croyez pas qu'on est une
caste au dessus des autres qu'on est
impassible impassable on vit aussi on
est des êtres humains aussi un tous
ensemble et on évolue au gré de
l'actualité au gré d'une actualité qui a
été extrêmement changeant de cette année
avec cette peur de dire un jour blanc de
dire le lendemain noir avec des
consignes des restrictions
gouvernementales qu'il a fallu analyser
à la minute près puisque c'est comme ça
aujourd'hui il faut publier l'info
rapidement et à la fois sur et à la fois
source et est à la fois crédible et à la
fois précise et vraiment cette année
c'est dans cette année 2020 on a eu
vraiment un cocktail qui a été très très
très difficile qui a été excitant qui a
été palpitant mais une année aussi dans
laquelle on a pu apprendre apprendre
autrement à fabriquer l'information à
attendre parfois avant de s'exprimer je
faire le point très bas avec thibaut
aussi que mon fidèle acolyte on est on
est une équipe aussi bonne
comment comment vous l'avez vécu cette
année sur le plan professionnel
je dois dire pierre comme vous l'avez
dit que c'était une année à la fois
terrible et excitante
on a vécu beaucoup de choses tant sur le
terrain que bien en direct avec vous sur
twitch sur facebook sur youtube sur la
page principale du figaro et ben voilà
des choses gravissimes des choses
parfois plus joyeuse des choses aussi
bien importante à couvrir en tant que
journaliste moi personnellement et avec
vous à chaque fois de l'autre côté en
plateau pour pas pour animer tous ces
contenus
j'ai pu couvrir l'ensemble des
mouvements sociaux qu'on a eu on a eu
beaucoup cette année a commencé dès le
début de l'année 2020 par la mouvement
pour la réforme des retraites
ensuite on a eu aussi et bien tous les
mouvements sociaux qu'on a pu observer
avec les conséquences économiques de la
crise du coc vide on a observé également
cette manifestation assez symbolique
importante des pompiers l'année dernière
qui se sont très bien
opposés aux forces de l'ordre et donc là
on a pu voir vraiment des images très
fortes et donc mais on va là ce n'était
pas sans risques cette année mais on a
pu observer beaucoup de choses à savoir
aussi les dernières manifestations que
j'ai pu couvrir contre la loi de
sécurité globale et le schéma national
du maintien est donc bien voilà c'est
dans cette
dans cette ambiance marquée aussi par le
vide qu'on a pu couvrir pierre ensemble
pendant et bien des semaines entières à
partir de nos domiciles respectifs
et bien voilà on était au quotidien avec
vous pendant des heures et des heures
pour vous faire tuer et puis on prend
actuellement des nations entières depuis
nos domiciles en enjoignant les experts
par skype grâce à amiens il faut saluer
julien qu'une elle aussi qui est notre
réalisateur et on espère qu'il va rester
notre
dix acteurs de direct qui est un
magicien c'est un gamin de 22 ans
bientôt 23 je crois est vraiment c'est
quelqu'un qui fait des prouesses au
quotidien vous avez un problème il aura
la solution est vraiment il nous a sorti
de situations incroyables il a il a créé
des choses pour nous qui nous ont permis
de faire cette actualité depuis chez
nous depuis presque notre salle de bain
on aurait pu faire des vagues sur la
douche sont roulés c'était c'était
incroyable et dans cette équipe il faut
six avions et julien qui nous a
accompagné cette année ils sont qui bat
tous adam
n'aurait pas été possible un petit tour
tiens je vois fasel qui nous envoie un
salut d'alger ben on salue alger
également qui est avec nous ce soir
dites nous comment ça se passe aussi du
côté de l'algérie
du côté de la capitale est ce qu'il y a
des gens dans les rues est ce que ça
paye fait évidemment l'algérie aussi
alors est-ce que ça est-ce que ça
festoient ce soir où est-ce que et bien
on est sur des contraintes comme bien
dans d'autres nations dans de nombreuses
autres nations n'hésitez pas à nous le
dire je vois d'aussi des titres
qui arrive
leila d'eric clapton c'est ce qu'ils
écoutent etienne ce soir merci d'être
d'être avec nous et merci pour vos
messages
merci d'avoir répondu à ma question nous
dit qui rira merci d'avoir répondu à ma
question mais ce n'est pas un vrai
couvre-feu alors il ya toujours il ya
toujours débat en tout cas ce que je
peux vous dire ce sont des propos très
récent du ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin depuis le couvre feu le 15
décembre
les forces de l'ordre ont procédé à plus
de 560 milles contrôle donc plus d'un
demi million de contrôles 30000
verbalisation au total et puis on
rappelle que toute violation du couvre
feu est passible d'une amende de 135
euros qui peut monter à 3750 euros en
cas de répétition des faits donc voilà
pour les chiffres qu'on a à vous donner
alors pouvez-vous nous montrer des
images du 93 de seine-saint-denis alors
je vais regarder si on a des images
d'autres régions qui nous parviennent
malheureusement alors nos confrères de
la fp sont à l'heure où je vous parle
partie sabrer le champagne semble-t-il
puisque nous n'avons pas d'image qui
nous parviennent en direct d'autres
régions françaises où d'autres pays
en tout cas etienne vous nous dites de
votre côté à l'île maurice pas de co
vide ni de confinement m'a écouté vous
avez une chance j'ai une chance
incroyable des derniers territoires du
monde où on annick hovine nini
confinement mais on vous souhaite de si
vous y êtes un jeu pas bien compris ce
que vous y êtes en ce moment en tout cas
en vous on vous souhaite d'y rester le
plus longtemps possible
toujours bien ces images en direct de
thibault il aurait sur sur les champs
elysées
faisons un point sur le nombre de points
de contrôle justement vous qui avait
remonté les champs thibault escales de
nombreux points de contrôle ou est ce
que c'est le dispositif est assez
discret assez léger comment ça se passe
alors non le police le dispositif
policiers et gendarmes et
particulièrement imposants avec depuis
tout à l'heure des véhicules de tous
types
que ce soit des motos les camions
voitures qui circulent pour
littéralement quadrillé temps cette
place de l'étoile que l'avenue des
champs-elysées et donc alors là vous
verrez de façon assez lointaine mais
est-ce que vous pouvez observer c'est
que littéralement un seul côté et
emplois occupés par des véhicules qui
sont bien très très très limitées dans
leur circulation et qui ne peuvent donc
pas forcément descendre cette avenue des
champs-elysées en revanche vous envoyer
encore quelques-uns qui peuvent remonter
l'avenue en provenance du centre de
paris est donc bien
là vous pouvez le voir je vais essayer
de zoomer pour vous montrer mais on peut
observer dans de nombreux gyrophare sur
l'ensemble de cette avenue
attendez hop voilà le temps que ma mise
au point ce fait vous allez le
comprendre et l'observer et vous allez
pouvoir justement voir que cette avenue
des champs-elysées var attendez on va
essayer de up excusez moi petit réglage
automatique
alors là il fait froid le matos n'est
pas en bonne forme voilà il vous pouvez
donc l'observer cette image c'est
symbolique 1 d'un côté de l'avenue qui
est littéralement occupé par de nombreux
gyrophares et de cette voiture de police
qui quitteraient très belles images qui
sont saluées thiébaut par nos viewer de
twitch nos lecteurs du figaro.fr et des
spectateurs sont
merci à toutes et à tous d'être d'être
là on est encore ensemble pour un petit
moment
merci d'être là je regarde ici vous fait
beaucoup rire avec vos dessins docteur
m'apprendre bon j'arrête la tartiflette
après je vais exploser
oui alors évidemment le
le médecin sera pas forcément d'accord
avec une consommation excessive de
tartiflette mais qu'est ce que c'est bon
la tartiflette qu'est ce que c'est
incroyable la raclette aussi qu'est ce
que c'est bon on est franchement faites
vous plaisir on est dans une année où il
faut faire mon sort d'une année et on va
rentrer dans une annexe un début d'année
qu'on nous annonce compliquée ces
manuels m'apprend qu'il a dit tout à
l'heure faisons nous plaisir c'est pas
grave
n'ayons pas peur de manger trop de
tartiflette je vois deux points qui nous
dit toujours pas de chiffre des voitures
brûlées n'ont toujours pas de files de
voitures brûlées mais on ne manquera pas
de vous alerter dès qu'on verra un début
de fumée
issu de la capitale ou d'une autre ville
mon cher internaute pour vous on pourra
même être le jingle buts tient qui a
dans les multiplexes de foot si vous
voulez pour vous signaler la la moindre
voiture brûlée tiens j'ai appris quelque
chose aujourd'hui en lisant le figaro
aussi c'est que certains profitent et
justement des réveillons et des voitures
brûlées lors des réveillons pour bien
mettre discrètement le feu à la leur
pour une escroquerie à l'assurance quoi
c'est à dire en gros bras tiens ma
voiture a brûlé on va vouloir payer
je profite de l'effervescence malsaine
pour ce côté là autour du réveillon du
31 mai est effectivement un c ça fait
partie des dés voilà des la magie du 31
chez certains fortwo cadence et c'est
une escroquerie nation c'est grave
merci aussi à sa yves d'être avec nous
sur le figaro.fr
merci d'être là dit nous aussi comment
ça se passe pour vous ce soir est ce que
vous êtes en petit comité en comics
terme peu plus grand qu'est ce que vous
regardez qu'est ce que vous écoutez
qu'est ce que vous mangez ce soir notre
non pas s'asseoir ensemble et votre vote
réveillons nous nous intéresse
franchement je comprends que ceux qui
sortent quand même joue un peu à la
roulette russe nous dit qu'ils rient
rabat écouter et vous vous avez intérêt
en tout cas avoir un compte en banque
ac après assez provisionné 1 pour si
vous fassiez vous braver les interdits
ce soir puisque c'est comme les autres
jours 135 euros d'amande et pour rappel
pierre ces 200 euros c'est vous
récidivez en moins de quinze jours et
c'est jusqu'à 3750 euros et près de six
mois de prison
si vous récidivez souvent mois plus 3
mais si tu en tires nos internautes de
twitch aussi nos joueurs de switch me
off stewart qui qu'on n'avait pas vu
depuis un moment merci d'être avec nous
ça nous fait plaisir pour voir un des
anneaux viewer du confinement c'était
c'était très bon souvenir également et
archivistique inédites y restent y
aurait pas une petite interview de
petits bouts avec les gendarmes se
compliquèrent d'interviewer légende est
ce qu'on peut avoir les coulisses
thibault sur le ces mécanismes me
permets de l'interviewer d
bah c'est simple on ne peut pas il faut
faire une préparation en amont avec la
dicom en général ça c'est que ce qui
concerne la police pour ça c'est l'
agence de communication des dépenses de
l'ordre qui vont organiser des
reportages directement avec certaines
escouade certains membres qui vont
montrer un petit peu leur quotidien
mais ça c'est c'est très particulier
c'est aussi un prisme très particulier
qu'il faut garder en tête et donc on
allait les forces de l'ordre en présence
n'ont pas le droit de s'exprimer ainsi
je vais pour interviewer n'importe
lequel les gendarmes ou policiers qui
m'entourent eh bien je vais me faire
recaler avec politesse
alors je vais lui en parler de vous en
préparant le live donc on parlait de
vous on parlait de claire aussi qui est
une de nos fidèles sur twizz de frais
déjà comme quoi vous nous avez marqué on
est ravi de vous revoir pour voir ce
soir qu'un pour orchies comme pour les
autres dites nous comment vous
réveillonner ce soir dit nous
quel est le menu quel est le programme
est ce que vous allez regarder david
guetta tout à l'heure où est ce que vous
allez regarder je vois que ça se passe
chez nos confrères de bfm tv
d'ailleurs ça va pas tarder à commencer
du côté de notre dame
un spectacle également
orchestré par jean michel jarre pouvez
vous nous faire voir un contrôle de
police nous demandent de points sur
lefigaro.fr leur thibault je sais pas
dans quelle mesure ces possibles voilà
est-ce qu'on peut s'approcher je voulais
me retirer pour qu'on puisse aller voir
ensemble un contrôle de police grâce
c'est ce plaisir qu'on à faire des live
en direct et interactif qui sont assez
uniques sur internet pas des nôtres mais
en tout cas ce format et voilà n'hésitez
pas si vous souhaitez voir certaines
choses on peut s'approcher montrer des
choses et je vais vous montrer en direct
va sans commentaires pour vous puissiez
vous imprégner un petit peu de ce qu'ils
y ait de ce qui se fait
voilà vous le voyez donc cette rapide
contrôle je vous le disais tout à
l'heure qui est vraiment en tout cas
semble-t-il je ne peux observer mais
sous le signe de l'apaisement est en
tout cas la défaite puisque vous l'avez
vu ce scooter qui a pu circuler très
rapidement
samba sans être alignés tout simplement
et donc voilà des contrôles quasi
systématique en tout cas ici à ce point
qui vient filtrer l'entrée des
champs-elysées après tous les véhicules
qui circulent sur la place de l'étoile
peuvent continuer de circuler mais en
tout cas ici s'ils souhaitent accéder
aux champs elysées ça va être sous
contrôle obligatoire et donc je vous
l'expliquais tout à l'heure aux côtés de
laval d'échangés lisez et qui vient ici
vers la place de l'étoile est lui un peu
plus occupé avec des contrôles qui au
long dur où j'étais tout à l'heure en
début de séance
merci merci pour ces précisions long
thibaud bonne année bonne santé nous dit
alexandra sur youtube merci alexandra on
on vous embrasse par écran interposé
également on vous souhaite une
excellente année aussi
bonsoir aurions bonsoir chantal moi je
suis chez moi bien au chaud et c'est la
fête sur youtube avec plein d'abonnés
c'est gratuit c'est super à écouter
chantal on vous embrasse également merci
d'être d'être avec nous tiens je vois
aussi un petit coucou sur twitch 2 alors
adressé oui c'est ça c'est déjà la
vieillesse la vue baisse et le
mérignacais bonjour un petit coucou un
bon soir un petit coucou de passage je
suis dans la gironde dans le 33 bordeaux
mérignac bonne année bonne santé à toute
l'équipe du figaro qui fait un boulot de
ouf
très bon courage pour la saint sylvestre
à écouter ça nous fait vraiment plaisir
on espère que ce n'est pas derrière ce
message un membre de notre famille qui
se déguiser pour nous faire mousser
auprès de nos chefs
mais en tout cas merci dans ça nous fait
vraiment plaisir d'avoir d'avoir ces
messages docteur maboule ouais je suis
taquin thibault j'aimerais voir un
policier dire morning live de 7h à 9h
l'émission qui réveille tes voisins
l'émission qui aurait été abordée
ac c'est paraissant à mort ni lie mais
je sais pas ce que vous en pensiez
avoue-t-il
j'adorais
sans pas alors je vais vous décevoir les
seuls annonce que j'ai pu entendre mais
qui ont arrêté depuis maintenant une
trentaine de minutes mais les nombreuses
annonces que j'ai pu entendre c'était
tout les 10 5 5 10 minutes et c'était
gendarmerie nationale veuille et rentrez
chez vous au site
le confie le conte le couvre-feu a lieu
de 6,2 juste 20h pardon à 6h du matin
rentrez chez vous c'est ce terme qu'on a
eus rang restez chez vous pendant le
confinement bas ce soir pour ce nouvel
an sur les chances est bel et bien
rentré chez vous alors bien des plans
picasso n'en fait au mégaphone oui tout
à fait j'ai pu vous en montrer un tout à
l'heure qui est normalement utilisée
pourrait bien adresser des sommations
lors des manifestations vous savez c'est
plusieurs sommations qui est bien prêt
c'est de l'emploi de la force par les
mains des forces de l'ordre en maintien
de l'ordre est donc ce soir eh bien il
est utilisé pour appeler les citoyens à
rentrer chez eux est d'ailleurs un petit
anecdote mais que vous pouvez retrouver
sur mon twitter personnel j'ai couvert
une manifestation fin décembre juste
avant le réveillon de noël est donc bien
ce méga fan qui a été utilisée pour une
pour une sommation par les forces de
police les forces de police qui ont
conclu leurs sommations par un joyeux
noël et ça c'est assez rigolo a en tout
cas en tête avec ses services ça fait du
bien de voir certaines choses après
après les terribles images qu'on a vu
parfois ces dernières semaines bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir alors au fus qui
est avec nous ou fouquette avec nous un
fidèle aussi de twitch qui aimeraient
qui est ravi de passer le réveillon avec
nouba écouter ça nous fait plaisir aussi
nous avoir le mérignacais qui nous dit
non non pas du tout je suis streamé dans
la vie donc je suis pas un membre de
votre famille caché bombes à écouter
voilà merci en tout cas pour le
sympathique message que vous nous avez
envoyé tout à l'heure on suit 7
patrouille de police ces contrôles qui
sont en sang qui sont on est ensemble et
ses contrôles qui sont en train de se se
dérouler vous continuez de nous envoyer
vos messages
dites nous ce que vous attendez votre
chien votre plus grand souhait pour 2021
c'est quoi dites le nous dites le nous
dans le tchat sur twitch sur twitter
j'allais dire sur un mélange de switcher
de twitter sur tweets sur lefigaro.fr et
sur youtube
tiens twitch c'est une des plateformes
et twitter également c'est une
développement sur lesquels vous pouvez
retrouvez vous pourrez voir en direct le
concert de david guetta tout à l'heure
un peu avant un peu avant minuit concert
du côté du louvre pendant qu'on voit nos
confrères qui sont en train de filmer en
direct un contrôle auprès d'un deux
roues le contrôle d'un deux roues en ce
moment au pied de l'arc de triomphe
merci en tout cas d'être merci thibault
pour ces images et merci d'être avec
nous dans le tchat
rake est avec nous tranquilles ou quoi
tranquille merci d'être avec nous est-ce
que ça redonne va venir en live nous
demande
fallou mme bah écoute et non sordo je ne
va pas proposer de venir écouter on peut
si nous en temps on peut le lui
proposait de nous faire un raid 1 s'il
est en train de trimer
actuellement une question de thomas ol
tv qui est avec nous est ce que le
protocole
alors je vais prendre votre question
alors c'est une question pour thibaut st
concernant le protocole de gendarmerie
est ce qui peut être renforcée par le
déploiement de crs en cas de besoin des
boutons vertigo
c'est qu'il ya eu sans me demander la
police et des gendarmes qui ont été
certes organisé ce soir j'ai pas
d'informations sur l'origine de cette
mobilisation est ce que les crs sont
mobilisés ce sport en général ils sont
mobilisés pour des causes de
l'entraînement plus tôt de de régulation
nos zones publiques n'ont pas
d'interpellation ou de contrôle qui sont
faits relativement plus par les forces
de l'ordre de la police ou les gendarmes
donc en tout cas ici sur sur cette
avenue d'étoilés le long des champs
elysées je n'ai pas observé tellement de
crs réunit les forces de fait reste donc
la réponse voilà voilà ce qu'on peut
dire si vous avez des questions sur le
contexte sécuritaire sur ce nouvel an
n'hésitez pas on sait que 40 milles sur
ces 100 mille membres des forces de
l'ordre quarante mille gendarmes sont
mobilisés notamment sur les axes
secondaires qui permettent de rallier
les villes on pense aux petites routes
on pense au départemental par exemple
j'ai une question nous dit kirikou loup
qui nous dit bonsoir les journalistes
merci d'être là
oui les pétards alors est-ce que les
pétards sont
interdite qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre
à notre internaute thibault sur la
question des pétards les particuliers
[Musique]
puis ya des stades il ya des situations
différentes en fonction des territoires
par exemple dans le département du gard
les feux d'artifice et les pétards sont
interdits à la vente depuis hier matin
depuis ce matin bardon depuis ce jeudi
matin 6 heures et ce jusqu'à dimanche
voilà c'est une décision qui a été prise
il ya également des restrictions sur les
ventes d'alcool je voyais ça en
préparant cela il va tout à l'heure
certains départements de l'ouest et du
nord qui ont donc
interdit la consommation d'alcool sur la
voie publique
parfois dès la mi journée où la vente à
emporter comme dans les côtes d'armor le
rhône l'ille-et-vilaine voilà la vente
d'alcool à emporter est interdite depuis
la mi journée
on craint un relâchement des gestes
barrières qui pourrait contribuer à
accélérer le virus parlons du virus
également autour de 20 mille nouvelles
contaminations un peu moins de 20 milles
aujourd'hui ce sont les chiffres qui ont
qui sont remontés qu'ils sont parvenus à
santé publique france
je retourne tient sur lefigaro.fr je ne
vous oublie pas
alors de notre internaute qui s'appelle
deux points qui s'étonne du contrôle
qu'il a pu voir en direct sur figaro
live grâce à vos images un thibaut tout
à l'heure c'est ça le contrôle trois
points d'interrogation sous-entendu ben
voilà c'est entendu c'est laxiste
j'imagine ce que sous-entend notre notre
internaute
on imagine que bah si tout est en règle
tout est en règle un thibault
exactement peut-être que ces véhicules
qui circulent que l'on a pu voir en tout
cas avec
son esprit festif compagnie pardon je
disais donc peut-être que ces véhicules
qui sont pas
disposer d'une attestation faut pas non
plus voir le mal de l'autre côté je
tiens quand même à signaler dans ce
qu'on a pu observer au niveau des
déclarations du gouvernement et des
différences des autorités en tout cas où
ce qui fera en cette soirée du nouvel an
est aussi celle du réveillon de noël
c'était quand même un apaisement des
contrôles dans un contexte déjà
particulièrement tendu avec les forces
de l'ordre on se souvient de cette
manifestation gigantesque qui est venu à
paris au cours du mois de novembre qui a
rassemblé des dizaines de milliers de
personnes
la république jusqu'à la bastille malgré
des débordements en fin de manifestation
assez important et donc dans ce contexte
c'est assez difficile
là il faut aussi savoir que en cette fin
d'année toujours symbolique puisque dans
notre culture occidentale
je transmets mes ordres défense de lens
sont à la peine alors il va être pour
toi merci et merci pour ces précisions
thibault je vois que on a pas mal de
questions toujours nos intérêts qui sont
nombreux ce soir sur sûr
sur tweets sur lefigaro.fr et sur
youtube où thomas howell tv en parlant
de pétasses qu'un feu d'artifice sur la
tour eiffel
alors non il n'y aura pas de spectacle
comme chaque année cette année le
spectacle qui a lieu en temps normal un
niveau de la réponse de l'étoile est
annulé il va falloir se contenter les
différents spectacles qui ont lieu elle
avait rappelé tout à l'heure au louvre
du côté bien besoin d'enchaîner sort non
pardon à notre dame du côté jean michel
aulas au louvre du côté de david guetta
et versailles du côté d'un grand nombre
d'artistes français disent qu'on
représente
alors il va falloir choisir entre jean
michel jarre et david guetta parce que
david guetta ses 23 heures 45 ce sera
diffusé notamment sur tweets sur
twitter sur instagram jean michel jarre
ça commence un tout petit peu plus tôt
c'est 23h25 je suis en train de regarder
parce que c'est donc on va alors vous
nous demandez vous êtes beaucoup aussi
nous demander ce qu'on pourra voir sur
figaro live ses concerts malheureusement
non puisque nous ne sommes pas détenteur
des droits
c'est bfm tv qui a les droits pour le
concert de jean michel jarre c'est un
partenariat avec la mairie de paris est
en fait je suis en train de regarder ce
qui va se passer c'est assez
impressionnant ce qu'ils ont réussi
alors je pense que pour david guetta ça
va être incroyable et je pense que pour
jean michel jarre ça va être incroyable
également c'est ahurissant
parce qu'en fait jean michel jarre va
jouer depuis un studio et son avatar
sera à l'intérieur de la cathédrale
notre dame de paris virtuellement
reconstituer voilà comment ça va se
jouer tout à l'heure donc ça va être
assez acerbe ses portes
exceptionnellement pour les fêtes de
noël pour un spectacle musical meurtrie
par un incendie
jamais plus déjà couvrir exactement et
puis pour finir sur cette actualité
notre dame on pourra aussi parler de
l'orgue l'orgue de notre-dame célèbre
notre d'armes de notre dame dont la
dépose la dépose de l'orgue a été
effectuée est terminée elle a pris
plusieurs mois et elle s'est achevée il
ya qu il y a quelques jours dans le
cadre des travaux de rénovation
évidemment aidé de réhabilitation après
l' incendie beaucoup d'amour c'est ce
que vous ne souhaitez pour 2021 qui rira
merci merci merci pour votre souhait et
on espère et baky qu'il se réalisera
chez vous' au sein de vos proches chez
vos proches et pour tout le monde
asc mère johnattan aisèment et retient
est sévère c'est intéressant ça aussi
qui nous dit
bonne année à toutes et à tous merci
alors je pense qu'un petit peu puisque
ce message a disparu en tout cas qui
nous souhaiter une bonne année par
avance merci en tout cas pour vos voeux
ça fait plaisir
bonne soirée à toutes et à tous depuis
la suisse new deal with à merci merci
louisa pour votre message également
voilà dites nous ce que vous faites ce
soir on est ensemble pour à quelques
minutes encore pour faire le point sur
ce réveillon hors norme hors du commun
et oui et je souhaitais pierre faire un
petit parallèle d'actualité puisque je
me trouve ici sur l'avenue marceau qui
est juste derrière moi et s'est amené en
fait je les couvertes pour qu'ils
étaient littéralement une crise lors de
son éclosion en novembre 2018 est donc
cette avenue marceau que j'ai pu
observer notamment lors de l'acte iv et
qui était un champ de bataille littérale
avec le sol jonché de pavés de
différents projectiles de projectiles
des forces de l'ordre littéralement des
centaines de projectiles qui étaient ici
avec dans cette rue en face de nous avec
sacha bénite heures on avait plus
couvrir bien cette manifestation en
direct pour figaro live on avait vu des
choses qu'on penserait vraiment pas
avoir à paris et donc cette actualité
qui résonne particulièrement ici sur les
champs elysées on disait tout à l'heure
la plus belle avenue du monde mais il a
vu lui aussi qui a particulièrement
souffert depuis près de deux ans un mois
puisque bien tous les commerces qui ont
été bien fermés parfois pris d'assaut
par de nombreux manifestants
et tous les commerces aussi des ruelles
et surtout surtout les rues adjacentes
les petits commerces par des
indépendants qui est bien ont souffert
tout d'abord de cette fermeture tous les
samedis et ensuite et bien de ces
fermetures déjà beaucoup plus forte
depuis ce début de la crise du colis
merci thibault pour pour cette précision
on arpente toujours les abords des
champs elysées et celle qu'on appelle la
plus belle avenue du monde même si un
petit débat tout à l'heure dans le jet
pour voir et bien comment se déroule ce
réveillon hors norme cette année merci à
toutes et à tous d'être avec nous sur
sur twitch sur youtube sur lefigaro.fr
falloon qui réagit à vos propos un
thibaut la plus belle avenue mais qui
souffre des manifestations du coc vide
une avenue qui ne fait plus rêver et
c'est bien c'est bien dommage
c'est vrai qu'on a pas des heures à
répétition alors même si récemment ça
c'est ça s'est calmé mais on se souvient
évidemment et bien deux du mouvement
d'aidé gilet jaune qui avait entraîné
bien le saccage par certains de l'arc de
triomphe et des débordements nombreux
sur les champs elysées notamment le
fouquet's qui avaient été saccagés mais
aussi beaucoup d'autres restaurants
beaucoup d'autres commerces
d'ailleurs on voit on voit cette ce lieu
qui semble placardé un thibaut sur les
images que vous nous montrez qui a
littéralement la garde et de sa façade
est donc bas les hôteliers et tous les
milieux du tourisme de l'événementiel de
la restauration
tous ces milieux qui ont été fermés on a
pu suivre
on dirait que j'ai le plaisir de sur
cette manifestation
il ya quelques semaines la manifestation
des restaurateurs juste avant noël qui
est différent particulier de
l'événementiel du tourisme et de
l'hôtellerie qui ont manifesté sur le
champ de mars
et donc voilà c'est aussi un symbole et
en écho de cette période que nous vivons
si vous regardez à droite vous voyez un
autre commerce lagarde
en tout cas pour ces images un thibault
dites-nous toujours ce que vous faites
ce soir dans le che est alors il ya
quelques internautes choisir co qui me
dit mais débiles pourquoi tu demandes ce
qu'on fait on peut rien faire vous
faites forcément quelque chose vous
faites forcément quelque chose et
respecter la charte
ça fait pas de mal aussi alors qui rira
de zooey deuxième souhait pour 2021 à ne
plus voir de gilet jaune bon ça ce sont
vos propos et de toute façon c'est vrai
que le mouvement le mouvement
on l'a pas beaucoup vu finalement en
2020 ce mouvement d gilet jaune alors
évidemment avec les confinements
manifester ça a été quasi impossible
mais faisons un point justement
puisqu'on est sur l'échantillon sur les
gilet jaune
qu'est ce qu'il en reste de ce mouvement
moi j'ai en tout cas l'occasion de
couvrir tous les mouvements des gels et
jaune alors peut-être pas tous j'ai dû
concourir entre 40 et 60 mais en tout
cas j'essaye d'être le plus possible sur
le terrain pour couvrir ce soit des
manifestations de gilet jaune mais aussi
de tous les milieux qui descendent dans
la rue pour manifester et je peux pas
tout à fait d'accord avec vous pierre
jeudi a quand même que les gilets jaunes
ont gardé une présence ils sont certes
beaucoup moins nombreux à vraiment
largement moins nombreux mais ils sont
quand même présent à toutes les
manifestations jean nab servent à chaque
fois des dizaines parfois des centaines
et ils ont bien reconnu un gain un petit
peu de popularité et surtout de
manifestations ces dernières semaines
à commencer par le mois de septembre où
les gilets jaunes fait taire et bien
enfin fêter un anniversaire qui
approchait et surtout ce qu'ils
appelaient leur retour avant le
confinement on avait aussi observé une
manifestation assez violente je dois
dire j'avais j'avais couverte d gilet
jaune et c'est alors qu'on commençait à
parler du port de masques avec pour la
première fois des forces de l'ordre qui
portaient leurs masques et c'était juste
avant vraiment bien qu'on connaisse ce
confinement historique est bien plus
récemment il ya eu quelques
manifestations de gilet jaune juste
avant les fêtes j'ai pu couvrir une
manifestation des gilets jaunes devant
le conseil d'état qui vient manifester
avec des parapluies colorés puisque cela
faisait référence à l'interpellation de
moon une manifestante qui avait été
interpellé et en tout cas mis en en
interprétation par les forces de l'anp
et puis parce qu'elle portait justement
à parapluies colorés
voyez mine de rien les populations de
ces régions merci d'avancé précise john
hartigan j'allais dire que les
mobilisations avec des parapluies me
rappelle aussi hong kong en 2014
[Applaudissements]
exactement à la base c'est un rappel
rappelle à ces manifestations
et cette manifestante qui est là à
chaque manifestation je la vois à chaque
fois on avait choisi de faire référence
aux manifestants qui portaient notamment
à ce genre de parapluies et donc voilà
ça ça a fait ça fait écho est là pour
pour vous donner une actualité en tout
cas des prochaines manifestations
enregistrées dont la donne rendez vous
sur figaro legs ce soit sur twitter ou
en direct sur les différents réseaux
selon ce que l'on fera et bien il y aura
une manifestation de 3 janvier ça ce
sera en hommage à cédric souvient
l'homme qui est décédé des suites de son
contrôle par des forces de l'ordre il ya
désormais un an
ensuite le 16 janvier ça ce sera un
retour des manifestations contre la loi
de sécurité globale et enfin le 30
janvier merci pour cet agenda thibault
c'est vrai que un agenda de
manifestations qui s'annoncent bat
d'ores et déjà chargé pour les les
premiers jours de 2021 ue nous dit
gildas bien you gildas merci d'être avec
nous dites nous ce que vous faites ce
soir
comment vous voyez 2021 ce que vous
espérez on est en direct des rues de
paris des champs elysées pour voir si le
couvre feu respecté malgré ce
et bien mais malgré les entrées en
vigueur sont entre en vigueur depuis le
15 décembre et par le 24 on a eu on
était exempté bien on est sous
couvre-feu de 20h à 6h du matin depuis
munich maïque merci d'être là également
je regarde vos messages je vois des
salutations j'aurais salutations de
bamako bonjour à vous du côté du mali ça
nous fait plaisir de vous voir également
ce soir
ça très très vite là sur youtube
j'essaie de découvre messages en temps
réel bienvenue également bien toutes
celles et ceux qui nous ont rejoints sur
sur twitch un jeu voyait bras corse ce
qui est blanc corse pardon par brand
corse qui nous dit admirable thibault
entre 40 et 60 couverture de
manifestations de gilet jaune
journalisme de terrain un véritable
sacerdoce
écoutez merci pour votre message est
encore ce petit bois en temps puisqu'on
est en direct un ensemble et puis andré
andré sur lefigaro.fr qui nous dit je
suis à monaco tous les restaurants sont
ouverts vous avez bien de la chance
andré parce qu on est nombreux aussi
avoir envie de retourner au restaurant
ne serait ce que pour soutenir bien
cette branche professionnelle et puis
pour se faire plaisir aussi on va pas se
mentir
merci en tout cas andré pour votre
témoignage et on espère et bien que vous
repartirez avec quelques sous en poche
si vous avez joué au casino on vous
rappelle que jouer comporte des risques
sont le genre de ce genre de message
qu'il faut qu'on vous dise
à chaque fois qu'on parle de jeux
d'argent ou de boissons alcoolisées on
va se quitter dans quelques minutes on
va vous remercier à aller l'om tient
très beau message léon merci et léon sur
youtube d'avoir mis ce message
merci steam marseille intime marseille
si les résultats sont pas au rendez vous
en ce moment on va souhaiter à marseille
2-2 redresser un peu la barre lors de la
reprise dans quelques jours tiens je
vous propose on va se quitter dans
quelques minutes avec le feu d'artifice
du côté de moscou le nouvel an on va se
quitter avec ses images dans quelques
instants avant ça on va conclure ce live
thibault merci en tout cas thibault de
nous avoir fait vivre et bien
ces images en direct alors évidemment il
n'y a pas eu beaucoup d'animation
puisque bas ou couvre feu semble-t-il et
est bien respectée en tout cas dans ce
secteur de la capitale
en tout cas en ce qui concerne la
circulation il ya une circulation
minimum qui est inévitable puisque les
champs-elysées reste quand même une
grande artère de circulation de la
capitale en direction soit du nord de la
ville soit du centre de la ville est
donc bien vous avez pu voir depuis tout
à l'heure
des dizaines de véhicules être parfois
est bien contrôlée mais en tout cas à
circuler là vous pouvez le voir et c'est
assez intéressant à en direction de la
place de l'étoile les filtres ne se font
que à l'entrée de l'avenue des
champs-elysées il ya aussi et bien
quelques gendarmes à ma gauche qui font
procède à quelques contrôles mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est que les véhicules
qui veulent descendre sur les champs
elysées sont contrôlés à l'entrée de
l'avenue des champs-elysées puis pour
certains d'entre eux sont contrôlés une
nouvelle fois sur montceau cordon de
sécurité que vous allez pouvoir voir au
bout des cons point sera fait je vais
plutôt essayer de m'accrocher pour vous
montrer cela en direct et donc vous le
voyez bien un fameux véhicule peut être
contrôlé à plusieurs reprises ce qui
permet déjà de faire passer le message
de rentrer chez soi c'est un petit peu
le moto2 cette soirée est ensuite bien
de vérifier que la plupart des gens en
tout cas contrôler son bien en règle en
tout cas ont bien reçu le message
bakhit et merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
thibault pour c'est pour ces précisions
je voudrais
m'arrêter sur quelques derniers messages
ludovic merci pour ce live qui donne du
baume au coeur aux personnes ayant
choisi ou non de passer ce nouvel an
seule dernière question qu'on va prendre
thibault avez vous eu des retours des
forces de l'ordre sur les propos de
didier lallement
non alors j'imagine que vous faites
référence aux citations de 3,2 ce qui
pour les voeux du pré du préfet le
préfet qui a été appuyé par marlène
schiappa la ministre délégué à
l'intérieur qui est bien estimé que
c'était une belle citation je ne la cite
pas mais c'était un petit peu le message
est donc non non on n'a pas pu échanger
là dessus les policiers sont ici pour
faire leur travail mais moi je suis en
direct depuis tout à l'heure avec vous
depuis mon arrivée ici sur les
champs-elysées voilà en tout cas merci
beaucoup d'avoir été si présent dans le
chat ça fait plaisir de terminer l'année
avec vous et c'est un grand plaisir même
un honneur de la terminer avec vos
pierres merci pour votre travail aussi
six experts est si agréable avec lequel
j'ai pu travailler toute cette année et
voilà j'ai un petit bug de micro c'est
l'émotion
la machine si c'est vrai que les
machines on les a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup sollicité cette année ont pris
vraiment nous excuser pour à toutes les
fois eu des bugs des sautes c'est comme
ça et c'est quand même plutôt une bonne
nouvelle que l'homme soit plus fort que
la machine alors actuelle et puis voilà
je voulais envoyer un message spécial à
el niño sur youtube qui nous parle d'un
homard cuisinés à la californienne 870
grammes or carcasse el niño si vous avez
une adresse et un digicode à nous
communiquer avec thibault on sera ravi
de venir manger les restes en tout cas
merci beaucoup à toutes et à tous
d'avoir été avec nous cette année
je salue notre communauté twitch
notamment qui a été au rendez vous du
1er janvier au 31 décembre
lefigaro.fr évidemment alors youtube on
est arrivé sur youtube en live
un peu plus tard mais on est ravi de
vous avoir découvert accueilli d'avoir
pris vos questions souvent pertinentes
intéressante et qui font progresser
l'information c'est notre pari celui
d'un journalisme interactif est à vos
côtés et même comme caen ce soir il n'y
a pas énormément d'informations à
divulguer c'est aussi un plaisir de
s'inviter chez vous et de vous avoir
avec nous d'être d'être ensemble tout
simplement et depuis je pense le
printemps on en a tous besoin plus que
jamais merci docteur maboule d'avoir été
avec nous sur sur twitter merci ou faux
merci orchies ouarchiti happy new year
nous dire chirurgie tiba merci bonne
année à toutes et à tous aussi par
avance à l'année prochaine avec 2021
encore confiné audio fou
on espère que ce soit ce soit vraiment
les tout derniers jours de confinement
convives
si confinement il y à nouveau en début
d'année prochaine
merci à beebe merci à jean merci à au
contrat de conscience merci à tiffany
merci à mike d'avoir été avec nous
d'avoir regardé les illuminations je
vois vous remarque sur l'illumination
anna beaucoup d'amour pour tous pour
2021 merci anna pour vos messages
ça défile tellement vite j'ai même plus
le temps de lire je pense que je suis en
épilepsie photosensible eux
merci en tout cas toutes et à tous
d'avoir été avec nous sur sur youtube et
je salue évidemment notre notre
communauté le figaro.fr andré qui rira
prince du sud
merci à deux points merci à kristen
merci à cnc merci à aa dld on se donne
rendez vous très vite dans quelques
heures en 2021 finalement et merci
thibaut petit bois tout à l'heure parce
qu'on va voir un petit coup à la rédac
aussi on va fêter ça ensemble au 6e
passage à la nouvelle année et on se
quitte avec vos images des
champs-elysées et dans quelques instants
les images de moscou où le nouvel an est
en train d'arriver à très vite à toutes
et à tous et meilleurs voeux pour 2021
et pour conclure alors là c'est la toute
fin merci thibault pour ces images des
champs-elysées je vous l'avais promis
tout à l'heure le feu d'artifice à
moscou en ce moment pour célébrer le
nouvel an merci à toutes et à tous
d'avoir été avec nous on va se quitter
donc
[Applaudissements]
m
je souris
alors
combien moment